it was the security council's third
emergency meeting in a week
but the first in public and it started
with an appeal
by the u.n chief for the fighting to
halt
the census cycle of bloodshed terror and
destruction must stop
immediately all parties must respect
international mediterranean law and
international human rights law
reflecting the urgency of the moment
some council members had their foreign
ministers participate
that was also the case for the
palestinians
israel is the armed thief who has
entered our house and is terrorizing
our family it destroys
our homes oppresses our people
generation after generation decades
after decades and then claims a right to
security
that it denies us israel's u.n
ambassador accused hamas of
carrying out indiscriminate attacks for
political gain
and putting its own civilians at risk
israel
sees every civilian death as a tragedy
hamas sees every israeli civilian death
as a victory israel uses its missiles
to protect its children hamas
uses children to protect its missiles
even as the violence escalates the u.s
has blocked the security council from
speaking with one voice
emphasizing instead its own mediation
efforts
the united states has made clear that we
are prepared to lend our support in good
offices
should the parties seek a ceasefire
norway
china and tunisia have been leading work
to negotiate a joint statement of the
council
frustrated by the lack of security
council action on an
issue that's been on the council's
agenda for more than 70 years
china's foreign minister called out the
united states
as the only dissenting voice and
promised to keep pushing
until the council can speak as one
kristen salumi
al jazeera the united nations